Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速向大家预告一件目前正在发生的好事。如果你曾想过如何创造为你源源不断带来收入的管道，而不是用时间无休止地去换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊主办的“冲刺复利收入挑战赛”。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, I am guiding you through two important steps that can help you think about weathering the storm on your journey
这些原则同样适用于你。挑战赛中还有由丽莎本人赞助的丰厚奖品等你来拿。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士——进行一对一小时指导的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有细节发给你。好啦，让我们继续今天的节目。在今天的《有志心理学家播客》中，我将带领大家经历两个重要的步骤，它们可以帮助你思考如何应对旅程中的风雨，
to becoming whatever type of aspiring psychologist you fancy being. If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Here we are with another episode from the Marianne's Summer Soundbite series, which are going to be slightly shorter episodes than the standard episodes to help you to be able to
无论你想成为什么样有志向的心理学家。如果你想成为一名心理学家，就让这成为你的指南吧。有这个播客在你身边，你将迈向获得资格的道路。这就是由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的《有志心理学家播客》。嗨，欢迎来到《有志心理学家播客》。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。我们迎来了玛丽安夏季精华系列的又一期节目，与标准节目相比，这些节目的时间会稍短一些，旨在帮助你在今年夏天可能有点忙碌的时期里，
continue engaging with your goals for learning and development in psychology over this summer period when you might be a little bit busier. Don't worry, this isn't a permanent change to the format and the usual longer and guest episodes will be around over the summer and in the autumn again too. Another series that you might well know and love is the free Compassionate Q&A series. Don't worry, that one is back for the 2023 season too. Here's all the details you need to know. So as you can see on your screen we have the first of those coming up on Monday the 4th of September 2023 and that starts at 6pm. A replay will of course be available too and the best place to find the replay is Dr. Marianne Trent on YouTube. The second of the sessions is Tuesday, the 3rd of October, 2023, also at 6 p.m. Again, a replay is available.
继续推进你在心理学学习和发展方面的目标。别担心，这不是对节目形式的永久改变，在夏季以及秋天，往常较长的节目和嘉宾访谈节目也会再度回归。你可能很熟悉并喜爱的另一个系列是免费的“同情问答”系列。别担心，这个系列在 2023 季也会回归。以下你需要了解的所有详细信息。正如你在屏幕上所看到的，我们将迎来其中的第一场，时间是 2023 年 9 月 4 日星期一，下午 6 点开始。回放当然也会提供，寻找回放的最佳地点是在 YouTube 上搜索 Dr. Marianne Trent。第二场直播是 2023 年 10 月 3 日星期二，同样在下午 6 点。重申一下，届时将提供回放。
And the third and final session to support application season for the Declined Cyber, also EdCycle, is also a similar time of year, is going to be Tuesday, the 7th of November,th of November 2023 at 6pm. So don't wait, don't delay, connect with me on socials now so that you can dive right in when the time comes. On LinkedIn I am Dr Marianne Trent, come and connect or follow. On Twitter I'm also Dr Marianne Trent, although on Twitter I can't see your comments because StreamYard and Twitter
第三场也是最后一场旨在支持申请季（针对 DClinPsy 以及教育心理学博士等）的活动时间也在一年中的相近时候，即 2023 年 11 月 7 日星期二下午 6 点。所以不要等待，不要耽搁，现在就在社交媒体上与我建立联系，以便在时间到来时能够直接参与。在 LinkedIn 上，我是 Dr Marianne Trent，欢迎来连接或关注。在 Twitter 上我也是 Dr Marianne Trent，虽然在 Twitter 上我无法看到你的评论，因为 StreamYard 和 Twitter
don't integrate properly, but if you want to just watch from Twitter, you absolutely can. On YouTube, I am Dr. Marianne Trent. My Facebook page is also Dr. Marianne Trent. And last but of course not the least, come and join my free Facebook community group, which is called the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. I do always endeavour to get live on Instagram as well, but it's not quite so interactive because it means I have to get my phone rigged up behind my webcam. It's a little bit rusticic but you absolutely should be able to catch it there too. So the first of today's Summer Soundbites is all about self-care. I absolutely think it is essential. In business it's said that the more time and money even we invest in our own self-care
无法完美整合，但如果你只想在 Twitter 上观看，完全没有问题。在 YouTube 上，我是 Dr. Marianne Trent。我的 Facebook 主页也是 Dr. Marianne Trent。最后但同样重要的是，欢迎加入我的免费 Facebook 社区群组，名为“有志心理学家社区（与 Dr. Marianne Trent 一起）”。我一直努力在 Instagram 上进行直播，但互动性没有那么好，因为这意味着我必须把手机固定在网络摄像头后面。虽然有点简陋，但你绝对也能在那里看到它。所以，今天的第一个夏季精华系列是关于自我关怀的。我绝对认为这至关重要。在商业中有一种说法，我们投入到自我关怀中的时间和金钱越多，
the more productive we will be in business and the more lucrative that will be. This is absolutely something that I try to encourage among my colleagues and I want you to be able to do the same as well. Self-care isn't all face packs and eye masks, it isn't all spending money either. It might be that you make time as I I've always done, to stop for lunch and to do something completely different and not to eat lunch at your desk. That is an excellent, in my opinion, way to show yourself great self-care. And if that also involves a short walk before you head back to your desk or to see your clients, then all the better for it because we absolutely can get a
我们在商业中的生产力就会越高，收益也会越丰厚。这绝对是我试图在同事中鼓励的做法，我也希望你们能做到这一点。自我关怀不全是敷面膜和眼罩，也不全都是花钱。可能就像我一直做的那样，腾出时间停下来吃午饭，做点完全不同的事情，而不是在办公桌前吃午饭。在我看来，这是展现自我关怀的一种绝佳方式。如果这还包括在返回办公桌或见客户之前进行一小会儿散步，那就再好不过了，因为当我们从事心理健康工作时，确实很容易
bit sitting yes that word is sitting when we're working in mental health and an opportunity to get our heart beating faster and to get some fresh air and move those legs and the opportunity to get out there enjoy some fresh air to connect with with nature, to see, you know, who and what is about in your local area where you are working can be so powerful. And also, I find, can lead to creative ideas for how to tackle problems that you're struggling with, either with clients or with business processes in a different way. How can you prioritise exercise in your day-to-day life? So as I speak to you today, certainly when I'm recording it, I've been for a run, even just a short run, every day, every morning since the end of May.
坐着——没错，那个词就是“坐着”——而有机会让心跳加速、呼吸新鲜空气、活动双腿，以及走出户外享受新鲜空气、亲近自然、看看你工作当地周围的人和事，会带来极其强大的力量。而且我还发现，这能激发创造性灵感，让你以不同的方式去解决那些让你感到困惑的难题，无论是针对客户还是商业流程。你如何在日常生活中优先安排运动？所以今天我和大家说话时——当然是在我录制的时候——自五月底以来，我每天早上都去跑步，哪怕只是短短的一跑。
I absolutely recognise that my sleep is better, that my mood is better, that my fuse, my window of tolerance is broader. And it helps me make mindful choices about my eating too. All part of my strategy to nourish myself physically and emotionally. So if you've got young children, especially if you're a solo parent, it might feel difficult for you to leave the house to do something like that. But we all need to be able to exercise, even if you are a wheelchair user or you've got limited mobility, you need to be able to see how we can move our bodies in a way that is good for our body and our soul. I have some very fond memories of doing wheelchair or CT yoga classes with some of the clients that I used to support in the physical disability team.
我完全意识到我的睡眠变好了，我的情绪变好了，我的耐心、我的容忍度变宽了。它也帮助我在饮食上做出正念的选择。这都是我从身体和情感上滋养自己策略的一部分。所以如果你有年幼的孩子，特别是如果你是单亲家长，你可能会觉得很难离开家去做这样的事情。但我们需要能够运动，即使你是个轮椅使用者或者行动不便，你也需要看看我们如何能以对身体和灵魂都有益的方式活动身体。我有一些非常美好的回忆，曾与物理残疾团队中我曾经支持过的一些客户一起做轮椅或坐姿瑜伽课程。
So how can you make plans to move your body or to relax your body to do something a little bit more low key? It might be self care, such as relaxation or mindfulness. It might even be something a little bit more high-locked on, something that really feels like a joyful or fulfilling endeavour. I absolutely believe that you taking care of yourself well better equips you to be able to support not only those that you work with, but everybody around you too. Let's take a quick break here and I'll be back along very shortly with the next of Marianne's Summer Soundbites. Thank you. It's the clinical psychologist collective.
那么，你如何制定计划来活动身体、放松身体，或者做一些稍微低调一点的事情呢？这可能是自我关怀，比如放松或正念。它甚至可以是更具活力的事情，一件真正让人感到快乐或充实的事情。我坚决相信，你照顾好自己，能让你更有能力不仅支持那些与你共事的人，也能支持你周围的每一个人。在这里我们做一个简短的休息，我很快就会带着玛丽安夏季精华系列的下一期节目回来。谢谢。这里是临床心理学家集体。
Welcome back. So the next of our Summer Soundbites is all about celebrating achievements. Depending on how you were raised and some of the messages that you've given about yourself, either from those in your family or those around you, it might be tricky for you to feel like you can really lean in to the things that you've achieved and you've accomplished. But let me give you permission, if you need it it to do just that. It might be that you've completed a doctorate, it might be that you've completed your undergraduate degree or that you've handed in an assignment or that you're working hard on your masters or your postgraduate certificate. It might be that you're
欢迎回来。我们的下一个夏季精华系列是关于庆祝成就的。根据你的成长经历以及从家人或周围人那里得到的关于你自己的某些信息，你可能会觉得很难真正去肯定并沉浸在你所取得的成就和成果中。但请允许我赋予你这样做的许可，如果你需要的话。你可能已经完成了博士学位，可能已经完成了本科学位，可能已经交了一份作业，或者你正在努力攻读硕士或研究生证书。你可能正在
conducting research, it might be that you're writing something up for publication, it might just be the practical experience and the way that your knowledge and skills are shifting and growing. It might even be the way that you're engaging with supervision and how that is changing. Absolutely celebrate those. And whilst it can be tricky when we rely upon the external feedback of others, because that's thought to be an extrinsic motivator. If you're hearing good stuff, it is okay to feel good about that. And of course, we need to be able to do the intrinsic motivating as well. We need to have these things feel good just because of
进行研究，你可能正在撰写用于发表的文章，或者它可能只是实践经验，以及你的知识和技能在发生转变和增长的方式。它甚至可能是你参与督导的方式以及这如何发生改变。一定要庆祝这些。虽然当我们依赖他人的外部反馈时可能会比较棘手，因为这被认为是一种外在动机。如果你听到好评，为之感到高兴是完全可以的。当然，我们也需要能够产生内在动机。我们需要这些事情仅仅因为我们自己而感觉良好，
ourselves, not because of what someone else has said about them. I like to think about the stuff that's gone well for me or some of the lovely client feedback testimonials that I've had across my years, both in one-to-one work, in group work, and in my work with aspiring psychologists and for the Clinical Psychologist Collective book, the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book, and the Grief Collective book as little sort of nuggets to keep you know under my belt that I can draw on and lean upon on days where I feel a little bit more depleted. Each and every achievement in your journey not just professionally but personally is something that you can feel so proud of and that you should. If you have found this useful and you'd welcome some more permission to celebrate wonderful you and to grow and nurture and shape yourself
而不是因为别人对它们的评价。我喜欢把那些对我来说进展顺利的事情，或者多年来我在一对一工作、小组工作以及与有志心理学家合作时收到的来自客户的可爱反馈和证言，还有《临床心理学家集体》一书、《有志心理学家集体》一书以及《悲伤集体》一书中的内容，当作一颗颗小小的“金块”，放在自己身上，当我感觉精力有所枯竭时，我可以汲取并依靠它们。你旅程中的每一个成就——不仅在职业上，在个人层面上——都是你可以为之感到无比骄傲的事情，你也理应如此。如果你觉得这很有用，并且希望得到更多的许可去庆祝精彩的自己，去成长、滋养和塑造你自己，
but under my expert care and attention but also my hand-selected and crafted panel of experts that includes a CBT specialist consultant psychologist, research clinical psychologists and a whole host of specialist teaching and training practitioners. Why not check out the Aspiring Psychologist membership which you can jump on board for just £30 a month with no minimum commitment. Come and talk about how you find the podcast and let me know your ideas for future Aspiring Psychologist podcast episodes. In the free Facebook group. The Aspiring Psychologist Community. With Dr. Marilyn Trent.
但在我的专业关怀与关注下，同时也在我精挑细选和打造的专家团队的帮助下——其中包括 CBT 专家咨询心理学家、研究型临床心理学家以及一大批专业教学和培训实践者——为什么不来看看“有志心理学家会员计划”呢？你只需每月 30 英镑即可加入，且无最低承诺期限。快来聊聊你对这期播客的感受，并在免费的 Facebook 群组“有志心理学家社区（与 Dr. Marianne Trent 一起）”中让我知道你对未来有志心理学家播客节目的想法吧。
Thank you so much for making time to prioritise yourself. And to listen to this episode. I will be back along with the next episode from 6am on Monday. Thank you so much for being part of my world. Take care. then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist with dr marianne my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all
非常感谢你抽出时间优先照顾自己并收听本期节目。我将在周一早上 6 点带着下一期节目回归。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。保重。就让这作为你的指南，有这个播客在你身边，你将迈向获得资格的道路。这是由玛丽安博士主持的有志心理学家播客。我叫贾娜，是一名心理福祉见习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。
the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
令我惊奇的是，通往这一职业的途径竟然有这么多，而且并没有成为其中一员的完美方式。这在某种程度上让我充满了信心，让我觉得“不，我没有做错”，从而减轻了对自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你翻开这本书，你就不会再放下了。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。